we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a caller commenting on fox news
host laura ingram last week linking
cannabis to mass shootings take a listen
to this
hey david susan from chicago coming
commenting on laura ingram and her
ridiculous marijuana
um
conclusions
um i can assure you that people who
smoke marijuana are not out committing
crimes we are at home eating frozen
cookie dough in our pajamas so keep that
in mind
and uh have a nice day yeah and of
course this the stereotype of the
cannabis user
is relaxed low-key
not out there committing violent crimes
and generally speaking that's accurate
there are some studies we've talked
about which can link
cannabis to
people kind of predisposed to aggressive
behavior in some of them there have been
some studies that say cannabis can sort
of
enliven that tendency but no evidence
whatsoever of a causal relationship
between cannabis and violent crime
that's what the facts and the best
studies we have tell us as of right now
i don't even know that laura ingram
really believes it
uh but it's certainly something i mean
listen they'll latch on to anything for
the first few days after the texas
shooting it was doors too many doors
open doors unlocked doors
then it shifted to other things well
it's mental illness so what but you guys
always vote against funding for mental
illness well so it's probably some other
thing maybe now it's cannabis cannabis
psychosis is another thing they're
pointing to their only goal is
don't talk about guns that's the one
piece we can't talk about anything else
they'll blow smoke up your you know
wherever in your nostrils but the gun
piece you can't talk about we'll see uh
what happens over the next week with
this forthcoming vote in the house on
banning assault weapons
can democrats find 10 republicans in the
senate to get to 60
and would they have the votes of all 50
democrats is also a fair question
to pass an assault weapons ban i think
by friday we'll have a much better idea
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today among other stories we will talk
about the supreme court deciding to
allow states to use illegally
gerrymandered republican districting
maps
in the 2022 midterm elections what why
we will talk about that and much more on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
and remember that you can use the coupon
code big voting 22. surrounded by
water big water not big water just big
voting big voting 22 to get a discount
off of a membership at
joinpackman.com
one of our sponsors is magic spoon the
only breakfast cereal that tastes
exactly like your favorite sugary
childhood cereals but with zero sugar
only four net carbs and 14 grams of
protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto
you can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years how about
this if you try magic spoon and you
don't think it's amazing like we do
they'll give you your money back because
magic spoon stands behind their product
because it's that good you really can't
tell it apart from the classic cereals
build your own custom variety pack
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magic spoon dot com slash pacman and
use the promo code pacman the link is in
the description